kommt jetzt endlich der durchbruch
gelingt es uns die gesetze der
quantenwelt mit denen der allgemeinen
relativitätstheorie zu vereinen die
passt nämlich gar nicht zusammen klar
ist mit einer quanten
gravitationstheorie würde sich das bild
der realität umfassend ändern und vor
allem gäbe es keine dunkle energie sie
wäre überflüssig wort krieg substanzen
future gegen es dreimal pro woche
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und activity trocken nur so
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen
dieses video ist entstanden in
kooperation mit ried dem digitalen kiosk
fürs smartphone oder tablet führen der
regulären 999 gibt es nahezu alle
magazine und zeitschriften der link ist
hier unter me für euch mit einem
besonders günstigen sonderangebot und
wir haben dieses mega spannende thema
dort auf rigi in spektrum gefunden aber
es gibt noch mehr als 5000 weitere
magazine dazu aufrief
glee ist wie dass netflix für magazine
es sind die beiden eckpfeiler der physik
die allgemeine relativitätstheorie und
die quantenmechanik doch bisher ist es
der fachwelt trotz intensiver forschung
nicht gelungen diese zu vereinen beide
widersprechen sich sogar das ist exakt
belegt wie kann das sein klar ist die
quantenmechanik war und ist ein echter
meilenstein für die physik denn mit
ihrer hilfe lassen sich viele
physikalische phänomene erklären und
vorhersagen und sogar computer
quantencomputer lassen sich auf basis
ihrer gesetze bauen und dennoch hat sie
eine große schwäche denn auch die
quantenmechanik selbst macht es der
wissenschaft nicht möglich wirklich zu
erkennen zitat was die welt im innersten
zusammenhält diese anforderungen an die
wissenschaft findet sich übrigens in dem
wohl bedeutendsten werke der deutschen
literatur
die rede ist von faust geschrieben von
johann wolfgang von goethe und das heißt
dass theorien nicht nur dafür da sind um
experimentelle ergebnisse vorherzusagen
stattdessen müssten experimente
eigentlich auch dafür genutzt werden um
bereits bestehende theorien zu
überprüfen doch schaut man sich die
quantenmechanik genauer an schlussmann
schnell auf herausforderungen und
schwierigkeiten ein beispiel dafür ist
das sogenannte doppel spalt experiment
hierbei werden 1
teilchen und inzwischen auch ganze
moleküle also die verbindung mehrerer
atome auf eine undurchlässige blende
geschossen die von zwei parallelen
schmalen streifen durchzogen ist die
partikel oder moleküle beispielsweise
elektronen werden von einem
dahinterliegenden sturm detektiert das
ergebnis entspricht keineswegs unsere
erwartungshaltung denn die elektronen
hinterlassen auf dem detektion schirm
keinesfalls den schatten oder die
leuchtstreifen dieser beiden spalten
stattdessen entstehen auf dem detektion
schirm viele streifen dabei gibt es
einen bereich mit einer hohen und
außerdem auch einen bereich mit einer
niedrigen auf treff tigte genau genommen
handelt es sich um ein muster das
typisch für wellen phänomene ist also
nicht für teilchen und genau hier kommen
physikerinnen und physiker in
erklärungsnot und dieses
quantenmechanische phänomen zu erklären
bleibt mir nichts anderes übrig als
mikroskopische teilchen als wellen zu
beschreiben weiterhin geht man davon aus
dass die wellenfunktion dann aber
plötzlich wieder kollabiert denn im
experiment zeigt sich dass das elektron
auf dem infektions stimmen lediglich
eine punktförmige spur hinterlässt es
vereint wieder alle eigenschaften eines
teilchen und besitzt keine ausdehnung
mehr
dennoch bleiben einige fragen offen aus
welchen gründen kollabiert die
wellenfunktion sobald sie den
direktionsbereich und könnte sogar sein
dass sie erst dann zusammenbricht sobald
es ein beobachter gibt der den schirm
anschaut und das ganze klappt sogar mit
riesigen molekülen mit bis zu 810 atom
das ist schon ziemlich verrückt wie also
soll man das deuten was passiert da dazu
gibt es unterschiedliche
erklärungsansätze
bei der sogenannten orthodoxen
interpretation liegt es an der messung
die dazu führt dass die wellenfunktion
kollabiert doch auch hier gibt es noch
zahlreiche ungeklärte fragen ist dafür
ein beobachter notwendig und welche
physikalischen prozesse machen überhaupt
eine messung an sich aus weiterhin
fordert der orthodoxe ansatz etwas was
in der wissenschaft ein umstrittener
ansatz ist demnach sollte sich eine
physikalische theorie darauf beschränken
experimentelle ergebnisse vorherzusagen
weiterführende diskussionen seien damit
nicht nur überflüssig sondern auch
unerwünscht manchmal spricht man hierbei
auch von der kopenhagener deutung die
der us-physiker david man mal ganz
passend folgendermaßen zusammen gefasst
hat ab
kalkuliert also übersetzt so viel wie
klappe halten und rechnen
doch die fragen zur rolle der messung
und zur rolle des beobachters in der
quantenmechanik werden damit nicht
beantwortet ganz im gegenteil deutlich
gemacht wird dieses problem in den
berühmten gedankenexperiment des
österreichischen physiker erwin
schrödinger hierbei sitzt eine katze in
einem geschlossenen kasten und befindet
sich so lange in einem zustand zwischen
leben und tod bis jemand nach schaut
denn mit ihr zusammen befindet sich in
der kiste auch ein radioaktive atomkerne
der ein tödliches gift frei selbst so
weiter zerfällt die quantenmechanik ist
nicht in der lage zu erklären wann die
wellenfunktion zusammenbricht der
zustand des atomkerns und somit auch der
zustand der katze ist erst dann
eindeutig festgelegt wenn die umwelt mit
dem system interagiert wenn also
gemessen wird erst dann also wenn ein
beobachter die kiste öffnet und hinein
sieht ist das tier womöglich erst
eindeutig lebendig oder tot davor ist es
eben beides und das nicht theoretisch
sondern praktisch total verrückt doch
zurück zum kollaps der wellenfunktion
beim sogenannten doppel spielt
experiment dieses bislang unerklärliche
rätsel ist nicht die einzige
herausforderung die die quantenmechanik
mit sich bringt denn dazu kommt die
quantenmechanische wellenfunktion hat
nichts mit den wellen zu tun die man
ansonsten in der physik and klassische
wellen breiten sich in dem von uns
vertrauten dreidimensionalen raum aus
bei mikroskopischen teilchen die sich
durch wellenfunktion beschreiben lassen
ist das anders
festzuhalten bleibt also dass der
mikrokosmos trotz intensiver forschung
noch immer ein großes mysterium für die
wissenschaft darstellt eine mögliche
interpretation der quantenmechanik
stammt von dem französischen physiker
louis und ist schon um die hundert jahre
alt seine theorie wurde lange zeit von
der fachwelt nicht ernst genommen doch
mittlerweile steigt das interesse der
fachleute an der sogenannten de broglie
boom theorie dbb wieder sie liefert
einen der vielversprechendsten und
wahrscheinlich einfachsten ansätze dafür
die probleme der quantenmechanik zu
überwinden gelingt es mit ihrer hilfe
tatsächlich die gesetze der quantenwelt
mit denen der allgemeinen
relativitätstheorie zu vereinen
der profi selbst stellte die er
den in den 1920 er jahren auf und sein
us kollege david bogen verfeinerte die
theorie etwa 30 jahre später die poli
hatte sich von einsteins vorschlag
inspirieren lassen dass man licht nicht
nur durch wellen sondern auch durch
teilchen beschreiben sollte so
postuliert er das auch materie eine
wellenartige und teilchen artige natur
habe sein ansatz basiert also nicht auf
der wellenfunktion sondern beinhaltet
eben auch punkte teilchen wie in der
klassischen mechanik diese bewegen sich
im dreidimensionalen raum im
makroskopischen raum also bestehen katze
tische oder bäume beispielsweise aus
realen punktförmigen partikeln wobei
deren wellenfunktion verborgen bleibt
dennoch existiert diese wobei sie sich
durch ihre wirkung auf die teilchen
bemerkbar macht vergleichbar ist das mit
den ansätzen der klassischen mechanik wo
die kräfte auch nicht direkt sichtbar
sind sondern sich ebenso lediglich durch
ihren effekt auf objekte bemerkbar
machen wenn man diese überlegung auf das
doppel spalt experiment anwendet kommt
man zu dem folgenden ergebnis die dbb
wellenfunktion ist für alle einfallenden
teilchen gleich unterschiede gibt es
aber in der anfangs position und
geschwindigkeit und genau das führt dann
zu den verschiedenen auftritten und dann
noch die interferenzmuster zu erklären
müssten sich die teilchen vor dem
experiment in einem sogenannten
gleichgewichtszustand befinden
zusammenfassend kann man also sagen
lasst somit die vorhersagen der
gewöhnlichen quantenmechanik der
burschen mechanik entsprechen in den
vergangenen 20 jahren entstanden somit
konkrete anwendung der dbb theorie
beispielsweise hilft sie in der
physikalischen chemie weiter um komplexe
systeme mathematisch genau zu
formulieren die branche mechanik hat es
in diesem kontext möglich gemacht
neuartige und effiziente techniken zu
eröffnen jetzt geht es darum einen
weiteren schritt nach vorne zu kommen so
wurde beispielsweise in die gewöhnliche
quantenmechanik weiterentwickelt um
einsteins gesetze der speziellen
relativitätstheorie zu berücksichtigen
das ergebnis die quantenfeldtheorie mit
der sich subatomare teilchen und ihre
wechselwirkung untereinander erklären
lassen entscheidend hierbei die
sogenannte relativistische
quantentheorie basiert auf feldern die
die raumzeit durchdringen also sie
durchdringen nicht nur den
sondern eben auch die zeit ziemlich irre
die vorstellung in etwa also vorstellbar
wie bei einem elektromagnetischen feld
die anzahl der teilchen ist anders als
bei der quantenmechanik nicht festgelegt
partikel können entstehen und sich
wieder vernichten doch wie könnte ein
entsprechender relativistische
formalismus für die böhmische mechanik
aussehen diese muss verändert werden
damit der ansatz enthalten ist das
partikel erzeugt und vernichtet werden
können
bei der teilchen klasse der sogenannten
fermionen ist das bereits vor einigen
jahren gelungen unter anderem kam ein
forschungsteam um den belgischen
physiker watt strom zu diesem erfolg
doch damit die vollständige
relativistische theorie entsteht muss
auch eine weitere zweite teilchen klasse
integriert werden die so genannten
personen denn nur diese beiden teilchen
klassen gibt es fermionen und busen man
ist also schon auf halber strecke was
die verknüpfung von relativitätstheorie
und quantenphysik betrifft die bohrungen
werden der fachwelt für die grundkräfte
verantwortlich gemacht die fermionen
dagegen gelten als bausteine der materie
die quarks oder elektronen doch bisher
waren alle mühen erfolglos die personen
lassen sich einfach nicht als punkt
teilchen in die relativistische theorie
einführen und genau das hatte bogen
bereits zu seiner zeit geahnt
möglicherweise scheint es passender
felder zu verwenden die durch fermionen
wechselwirken und so auch personen
erzeugen und vernichten
dennoch ist auch klar dass selbst eine
relativistische quantentheorie nicht
eine theorie für alles ist und alle
bekannten physikalischen phänomen
erklären kann
denn die gesetze der allgemeinen
relativitätstheorie von albert einstein
sind nicht enthalten
dabei beschreiben diese die gravitation
gerade das ist ein weiteres super
spannendes rätsel der physik wie lassen
sich diese beiden bereiche miteinander
verbinden
eine quanten gravitationstheorie könnte
jedenfalls zu einem völlig neuen bild
der realität führen ein heißer kandidat
ist ja die stringtheorie bei der
schwingungen winzige eindimensionale
fäden zu elementarteilchen und
wechselwirkungen führen die wir
beobachten und das völlig ohne felder
oder gar teilchen ein weiterer vorschlag
für eine quantentheorie der gravitation
ist die sogenannte kanonische
quantengravitation physikerinnen und
physiker wenn hierbei die selben
techniken auf die allgemeine
relativitätstheorie an mit denen sie in
der vergangenheit auch schon klassische
theorie wie beispielsweise den
elektromagnetismus in eine quanten
version überführt hatte
bei der sogenannten schleifen
quantengravitation ist das ähnlich
hierbei werden die ein steinchen
gleichung quantifiziert und einige
variablen dann noch modifiziert der
unterschied zwischen beiden vorschlägen
ist groß bei der schleifen
quantengravitation erscheint die
raumzeit dies kritisiert raum und zeit
treten also nur häppchenweise auf anders
bei der kanonischen quantengravitation
die raumzeit erscheint hier
kontinuierlich bislang ist es den
fachleuten nicht gelungen mit hilfe von
experimenten herauszufinden mit welchen
vorschlag man richtig liegt zudem gibt
es auch bei diesen quantengravitation es
theorien ein entscheidendes problem das
mass problem das auch in der nicht
relativistischen quantentheorie die
herausforderung schlechthin darstellt
und das führt vor allem bei den
wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern die sich mit der
kosmologie beschäftigen zu unverständnis
und unmut denn so wird das universum als
ganzes beobachtet und es gibt keine
externen beobachter die messungen
durchführen zudem hängen die oben
beschriebenen theorien nicht von der
zeit ab das bedeutet dann im
umkehrschluss dass die wellenfunktion
des universums immer gleich sein müsste
wie aber kann es sein dass sich das
universum ausdehnt und es sich
entwickelt einige forschungsteams haben
sich in der vergangenheit damit
beschäftigt eine dbb variante der
schleifen quantengravitation zu
beschreiben die wellenfunktion ist
hierbei zwar statisch doch die
beschriebene raumzeit kann sich trotzdem
im lauf der zeit verformen
neue forschungsergebnisse in diesem
zusammenhang sind wirklich ganz
besonders aufregend und spektakulär denn
demnach sieht es so aus als könne man
dank der burschen mechanik auf die
dunkle energie verzichten
diese bisher unverstandene größe hatten
us for me teams in der vergangenheit
eingeführt um die beschleunigte
ausdehnung des universums zu erklären
heißt also vereinfacht gesagt wir
benötigen keine dunkle energie mehr um
die ausdehnung des universums zu
erklären das wäre echt der wahnsinn und
zwar sowohl für die kosmologie als auch
für die quantenphysik das thema stammt
aus wittlich eine app die ich schon seit
geraumer zeit nutze wenn man da wirklich
nahezu alles
wie zum beispiel hier quantenphysik in
spektrum der wissenschaft das führende
wissenschaftsmagazin ist auch dabei
allein dafür lohnt sich schon das ried
labor und es ist papier frei kein
einziger baum wird gerodet und auf video
gibt es noch weitere mehr als 5000
magazine und ich habe ein sonderangebot
für euch hier unter dem link gibt es die
ersten beiden monate für jeweils einen
euro 99 ab dann nach den zwei monaten
neun euro 99 und es kann jederzeit
gekündigt werden
der link ist übrigens auch in der video
beschreibung ich kann nur sagen viel
spaß beim lesen bis dann bleibt dran